And me,
as President of Catalonia,
to his Mechu,
the responsibility
gave double quech,
but do not depend on the irresponsibility of San
for the band to the country,
to the interests of the
yet,
and at another cost
and palmeu with van simen,
that the policy
it is not because it is based on responsibility
and in good vice,
and to continue to look to the future in all its might.
that U.S.
citizenship needs,
I have decided to call for action
SAO parliament
to opulate damage,
amlobyactiuca is Pugui dutá of 1 government
Am much mes,
Come on
to continue Fen advanced to the country
and exhale Ankara month the transformations
and feru sensei sinsa da pandencia
of real estate agents